communication is one of the men behind
the robobee project and we also just saw
him in this film and he has brought one
of his projects with him in the studio
today Tim Landgraf thank you for being
with us today all right so this is what
you call a neuro copter
that's our neuro company oh that's
that's a unique all right and why is
this you can how is this helping you in
bee research well in Robo in the project
role will be we are interested in how
bees communicate but it all goes to how
they actually you know accomplish this
in the brain and what brain structures
are responsible for storing those
locations because in the medians they
communicate those locations right
we know that the bees have a map of the
environment and apparently they they fly
out and learn the environment landmarks
in the environment and build up a memory
of this environment and we're gonna
understand how that works
so we build Neera copter and this is the
system is controlled by brain simulation
and we test models of different brain
structures that we hope would explain
how bees do it okay and I'm looking at
how these brain works and understanding
their communication I'm still not
exactly clear why this is important to
us well I mean this is basic science at
some point we understand how the bees do
it so we understand a little bit more
about the bee brain does it and then we
understand how our own brain does things
and at the end we understand us better
but as a as a robotics guy or computer
science guy I'm interested in in
building robots that that do marvelous
things and a part of this includes
understanding how we can have robots
flexible and learn
and intelligent and so I want to you
know use neural computation on robots to
make the robots smarter okay how can
Robo B's tell what can they tell us
about bees that we don't already know oh
we don't we know only a small fraction
of what there is I think I started with
you know those biologists and and it did
seem to be a very simple project and
then seven years later I'm like no
that's that's impossible I mean robot B
is still not finished we don't
understand why they follow because
sometimes they just don't and but why
you know so there are so many dynamics
in the hive that we don't understand all
right and we know it there's another
robot bee project in the United States
being developed by scientists at Harvard
University what are they doing
differently
oh they aim for autonomous small robots
that you know are used for pollination
of trees you know if you if you'd go to
California and and look at those almond
trees they they need eighty percent of
the whole population u.s. population of
bees to pollinate the tree so that's
that's a big market for those systems
okay
all right well we're gonna have to leave
it there for now but Tim thank you very
much is very interesting thank you for
bringing your latest project